so in previous videos we worked out an
expression for the current I in an LC
circuit like this and what we found was
that I is square root of capacitance
over inductance times the starting
voltage V naught times sine Omega naught
T and Omega naught is the natural
frequency and we said that Omega naught
was equal to square root of 1 over L
times C and V naught is the starting
voltage on the capacitor and our
original assumption was that I was zero
to begin with and that's the expression
for the current so what I want to do now
is a specific example and we'll do that
down here first I'm going to install a
switch into our into our circuit so that
we can add some energy and it won't go
anywhere then for C C is going to be
equal to a quarter of a farad and L is
going to be equal to one Henry all right
and on the capacitor I'm going to put
enough charge to bring this up to ten
volts before we close the switch and
then at time equals zero we'll close the
switch
and what we want to find is what is I of
T we have L we have C we have a starting
voltage and so now we have everything we
need to work out the current let's do
that okay so first off we'll do Omega
naught Omega naught equals 1 over the
square root of LC so that equals square
root of 1 over 1 Henry times 1/4 farad
which equals square root of 4 or equals
2 and that's in units of radians per
second that's the natural frequency we
know the natural frequency right here
and now we can work out the rest of it
so we can just fill in I equals square
root of C which is 1/4 farad divided by
1 Henry times V naught V naught was 10
volts times sine Omega naught T sine
Omega naught is 2 T and finally I equals
this is the square root of 1/4 or 1/2 so
that's 1/2 times 10 is 5 I equals 5 sine
2t
so for this specific circuit that's the
answer for this current here now I want
to show you what that actually looks
like so this is a plot of I of T equals
5 sine 2t and this is what a sine wave
looks like with time so the axes are
time and seconds and this axis is goes
up to 5 amperes and then down to minus 5
amperes and continues on that way and it
basically goes on forever and what I
want to do next is work out the voltage
in the circuit we didn't talk about the
voltage yet so I'll sketch the circuit
again here
here's L&C and this is the voltage right
here voltage across both guys we've
already worked out I and now we want to
find V what's V that's what we're
looking for so we know that I equals v
sine 2t and to find V one of the easy
ways to find V is to use the inductor
equation and we know that V equals L di
DT that's just the basic inductor IV
equation right and let's see what
happens here v equals L is 1 times di DT
so that's D DT of v sine 2t now let's
take that derivative okay I'll go up
here V equals v comes out of the
derivative sine 2t the derivative of
sine of 2t is 2 times cosine
of Tootsie all right so our voltage
solution is 10 times cosine 2t
so something interesting just happened
here let me show you we started with the
current being a sine function and we
eventually took the derivative of that
sine function and now we have a cosine
function so we went from sine to cosine
for voltage that means the voltage
doesn't look quite exactly like the
current okay let me let me show you a
plot of the voltage here's the voltage
here this is V of T and that we decided
was equal to 10 cosine 2t it starts at a
value of 10 at time equals zero and then
forms a cosine wave that goes up and
down between plus and minus 10 volts now
let me show you what it looks like when
we plot both I and V on the same graph
and we can see the timing relationship
between them
so this is a plot of I of tea in blue
and V of T in orange one of them is a
sine wave the current is a sine wave and
the voltage is a cosine wave so this is
what we were going for this is the
natural response of an LC circuit and we
had two specific component values in it
we saw that we came out with both
current and voltage looking like
sinusoidal waves this LC circuit this is
where sine waves come from in
electronics it's pretty cool